[Music]
things are dried up here
for me
[Music]
there's an opportunity where london
this would be our fourth move in ten
years backwards but money's fine right
yeah right yeah
this is a fresh start how about this
you shouldn't be working for someone
else
be your own boss build your own place
own your own horses something doesn't
feel right
it's not your job to worry you leave
that to your husband
scares me that you actually think that
[Music]
so you're back here full time oh yes
we've just bought a beautiful farm in
surrey and we're thinking
of a piedeter in mayfair this is small
talk
i saw some deposits you made it's
nowhere near what you're spending don't
worry
i have a huge check coming in at the end
of the month
everything's gonna be fine
[Music]
is it
you're delusional because you have
nothing rory we have nothing
it's horrible here no one is the same
here nothing is the same
here this house people
seem to want everything and expect every
need to be fulfilled
what is happening you're all strangers
to me right now all of you
you're embarrassing and you're
[Music]
exhausting what we always wanted
[Music]
[Music]
you